Bà cáo tổng hợp của người hôm nay, há bị chiến thằng chiến năm 2018 của 4 người và 1 chương.
Bà số 14 xói mạnh kém 1 lớn kéo dài đã người dân những thiệt hại đặc biệt nghiêm trọng bình người và tài sản tệ nhiều tình.
Tình đến chương này đã có 1 người 3 người từ vòng, 1 người 3 người mất tích và 1 mức sảo người bị thơ, tắm người mất lên là năng tổng số người từ vòng.
Mất tích, mất lên là và bị thương lên tới tắm người.
Trong đó, ninh bình kiến nhận chính người thiệt mạng sox lúc làm sập nhà, hương e'n 2 người, thơ thiên người 1 người bị nước quân chơi,
thêm hóa 1 người từ vòng xói kê đồ, khoảng chi hiện có 1 người mất tích, đàn nắng 1 người, 1 người xói bị thương phân bố tả nhiều đứa phương như mình.
Hà tính, khoảng chi, hương e'n, ngoài ra, 1 tộc cá ở dài lai với tắm nó độc đả mất lên là chiến bình từ tối ngày 2018 thằng chiến đến này.
Bà số 14 là 1 người 2 trong 8 người mua nhà tốt mái, tương hồng trong đó hà tính bị nặn nhất với người 1 người 3 người nhà.
Ngoài ra, tắm trong 8 người tương mua nhà bị nghiệp nước tại thêm hóa, nghe an, hà tính, khoảng chi,
hệ thống định lực tả nhiều tình tự thêm hóa đến khoảng chi bị mất định dựa dọc.
Hà lật kây xanh, cô định, cô phép thông bị gió báo của đồ,
cất tuyến đe binh đe xong tả nhiên bình, thêm hóa, hà tính, khoảng chi bị xật lượng nhiều vị chi.
Cất tuyến quốc độ, đường tình, đường đường đông thôn ở thêm hóa, hà tính, khoảng chi, hối, đàn nắng bị xật lượng,
ngập uống, chi cắt xà thông. Hà không cũng chữ ăn rộn nặn để với 1,5 xin bay bị vị,
5 xin bay hóa, báo số 1 người người người gương 2 gần xong nghĩnh hết tà lua và hòa ngọt,
cung hơn 1 người 3 trong hết tà thý xan. Dính nghĩ ăn có tới băng nghĩ hết tà lua,
hòa ngọt bị ngọt 1 người khu chăm xong biết xong hết tà lua trong thị xan hư 2.
Cất địa phương đặc biệt đồng tối đa lực lượng để hóa phục xe cố,
cư trưởng người dân vùng bị an gần. Bộ nông nghĩa và mối chừng cùng các bộ mình tiếp tục phối hợp,
chỉ đạo hình chương xử liết các điểm xật lượng, khóa phục hạ tần thiết iếu,
đảm bảo ăn tòa tính mạng và tệ sản trong vệ dân. Cơ quan khi tự thị văn dự báo,
hòa liêu xo báo sẽ còn tiếp tục quý mua tò, lối lượng và người cơ sật lượng đất trong những người tối,
người dân cần tương thủ hủ rung sức xe tán không chục quan quay lại nhạc khi nước chưa giúp
không xử dụng định khi chưa được đảm bảo ăn toàn. Chính quyền biệt phương phải kính báo khi tời,
dây dời dân ở vũi nghiệm dạm thiệu tối đa thị thải viên người.